have you had any fun or awkward stories
so far i remember you mentioned um
he didn't say this but i remember
hearing the story where
the delivery guys came
oh my god oh so bringing back to the
hole like when people first look at me
they expect me they just assume that i
know how to speak japanese yeah so uh
when we were getting our fridge
delivered we didn't have like
like an interpreter with us at that yeah
yeah we're just getting our fridge
delivered and installed same with our
washing machine
i was in another room during this time
but the fridge guy was trying to
communicate with didis yeah but
obviously like i just can't understand
what he's saying yeah so the delivery
guy was like
ah
honestly
[Laughter]
i feel so bad we have to communicate via
like google translate
but it's like at that moment i could
feel the disappointment i i can like you
say that story and i'm like i can feel
like his soul leaving his body just be
like [ __ ] i thought you were my crutch
and you let me down
this kid's just practicing all right
come on
i had the exact same experience but the
opposite when we went to when aki and i
went to disneyland and because aki looks
way more asian than me yeah people
assume immediately assume she can speak
japanese and i can't so
when there was like a staff member or
there was no there was a japanese woman
who like stopped us to like ask for
directions or something of course she
went to akira
and you know started speaking japanese
and this is like back when you know she
had just moved and didn't know that as
well
she wasn't as conversational as she is
now yeah speaking japanese blah blah
blah blah blah blah and then he's just
like uh no he's the one that speaks
japanese yeah and just like points to me
and i was like in japanese i was like oh
can i help you and the woman just looks
at me and it goes back to talking
and i'm like [ __ ] i just spoke to you
i can respond
she cannot why are you looking at her
i've experienced that too yeah i was
with david yeah and david uh speaks
really good
and we would go to like a restaurant and
the person at the front would like talk
to me yeah and then david would like
respond yeah yeah and then the guy's
like oh okay
and i'm like i don't know what you're
saying
i i don't know if you'll experience this
i don't know if it's because like i'm
white but
sometimes i have this weird moment where
i speak broken japanese and they speak
broken english to me and it's like a
battle of who's gonna who's gonna fold
first
um i i'm gonna i'm gonna keep doing this
i'm i'm really trying to get my hours in
here and he's like no no i'm gonna help
you i'm doing it i'm helping you out at
the moment there is fun back in brooklyn
english you just hear like the dark
souls like that
yeah
i'm not we're not full i feel like
process i'm like am i going to speak
back in english no i'm going to try i
can respond to this in japanese this is
fine
there's this difficulty level i can
handle yeah
because like
what i noticed with japanese people is
that the first language you speak to
them in yeah like no matter what like
the first language you speak to them
they will always try to respond to you
in that language like if you speak
english to them and then later on you
start you know trying to speak japanese
they would try to respond back to you in
english english yeah but i've also had
it where i've like even though i've
spoken like the most broken japanese
right i remember like
uh back when i was like
uh back when we had to get like cover
tests and we had to like phone up a
clinic together to get some code uh to
get
get a pcr test um there was this clinic
that apparently you know they they spoke
english right but i know what that means
right i know what that means
this is like the only time in japan
where they like actually just fall on
[ __ ] lies yeah yeah yeah they just
they literally click facebook yeah so i
phoned up the clinic and of course
they're speaking in japanese so i'm like
okay it's one of those i'm gonna have to
like practice my japanese so i start i
start speaking the most broken japanese
trying to book my appointment and
everything's going fine and then they
asked like a they asked like they asked
a question off the script right no just
like they asked a complicated question
that is like way above my level and i'm
just like uh
uh he starts speaking perfect english
i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like
like this is the one time you can start
speaking english and then he explains it
to me in perfect english right i'm like
oh great great i'm like okay that's fine
and then he goes back to speaking
japanese again and he was like
even though like he's like i'm done now
even though he can clearly hear that i'm
like really struggling with my japanese
what if that's the only line in english
that he can actually speak so continue
your free trial of english
like your 30-day trial has exploded
please buy winrar
it's weird because like every single
clinic i've been to that advertises like
english yeah it's always been like a the
doctor speaks maybe like hello yeah and
like maybe maybe can kind of explain
like
he kind of understands it's it's really
bad i mean i just went to one recently
right and hear the same thing and the
only time i've ever had have ever had a
doctor who spoke like perfect english
was one where they didn't advertise it
as being english right and the doctor
just was like oh yeah by the way i lived
in america for six years and studied
medicine and i was like
why didn't you advertise that you could
speak english like i would i would have
marketed for that like every single
other one says they speak english and
they don't speak english and like one of
them was is like attached to a pharmacy
right
so the doctor said that he spoke english
spoke like no word of english he didn't
so i was trying to explain i had a sore
throat and he was like
he he didn't uh know the word for throat
so i said it in japanese oh okay i get
it i was like you don't have the word
for throat
you're a doctor bro it's covered time
it's like one of the only things you
should know yeah yeah like what
so i i get my prescription i go over of
course the guy who's giving me the
subscription she starts speaking to me
in perfect english and i'm like
you should just swap with this guy you
should be the doctor you should swap
because i mean you basically same thing
right i think i i just take whenever you
go onto a clinic website or whatever and
it says oh it can speak english
i i just take that now as not the doctor
can speak english i just take that as
the doctor isn't afraid of foreigners
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's like and if
it doesn't say it then the doctor is
like oh [ __ ] i just walked in
no we're busy sorry it sucks because i
feel like i to get to the level of
proficiency in japanese to feel
comfortable
talking about really like what could be
sensitive information yeah like it could
be life or death information it's like
okay
even if i felt like super confident i
would still want someone who's native to
come be like can you can you help
explain it or i want english right
because you don't [ __ ] around yeah
there's there's a few things where like
i i'm fine trying to stumble through but
if there's one thing i'm not i'm like
health i'm just like i want to make sure
i'm communicating exactly what i need to
do
visa documents i like i'm i need to
[ __ ] know that i can get back into
the country all right to be fair like
you know i've been to some clinics where
they've said a japanese word and i'm
just like what yeah right yeah and then
i look it up in english and it's like oh
okay
yeah yeah but like you know i don't know
how to communicate that to the doctor
right so like it must be like
like 10 times more difficult i can't
take most medicine like most
over-the-counter medicine because most
of it like is uh i just for some reason
like you like pepto-bismol
ibuprofen all of that stuff i can't take
right it's like things your blood oh
um so i can't take any of that so like
when i'm talking to the doctor it's like
i have this condition i'm like it's not
a big deal like everything's chill super
chill just please don't give me medicine
i can't take it i'm begging you yeah so
like i learned the japanese word for
your condition
what is it when you got ah
because again the only time i use it is
when i had to go get medicine for this
guys
the doctor in the pharmacy that like oh
my friend has this condition but i
didn't know what it was in japanese i i
think i know the kanji for it because
i've had to brokenly write it out a few
times on forms and it's like like a
one-year-old wrote it yeah like i'm
pretty sure if you wrote country that in
china you wouldn't be allowed to
progress
it's like
or something like that something along
those lines you see how close
i don't actually remember
because that means blood okay okay okay
um
okay so i should know this because i
have it i probably should learn it
yes
i got kittens i know i know the kanji
because the first one's blood yeah and
then it's like like tomodachi kind of
looking ass it looks like
oh yeah
you know what language moment i
find so inspiring
a few years ago during the trip that i
was on to osaka with my mom and my dad
we actually got lost at one point yeah
and we couldn't figure out how to get to
the station we're trying to get to and
nobody that we were stopping could
understand us and we couldn't understand
them
and so we were like freaking out and
finally we find this police officer guy
who like walks up to us
and uh he starts like speaking to us in
japanese yeah and my dad's like oh no i
don't understand i like i don't speak
japanese yeah and this guy in perfect
english just goes he's like this old
dude in perfect english he goes what
language would you like me to speak
[Music]
and he starts rattling off in korean
what a badass yeah he's like one of
those like og language youtubers that
like i will give you a hundred dollars
if you speak a language i don't know
yeah
the fact that you can you can be
proficient in so many just to be like
give me one i'll put it out
he was literally just like name a
country that's so that's
such a [ __ ] flex yeah that's what i'm
saying if i if if i had to choose a
superpower my superpower would be i wish
i could speak everything
i would be being able to immediately
guess the country on geogaster by like
the landscape people are like oh this
sand only exists in like the northern uh
uh kenya actually uh and i'm like how
the [ __ ] do you know that of like a 10p
google pixel image what